hallo herzlich willkommen in S Welt ich
stehe gerade in Ferl bei nobelia auf der
Hausmesse und entdecke hier gerade die
neuesten Küchen dazu gibt's auch bald
ein Video aber ich habe mir jetzt
gedacht wenn ich schon hier bin dann
probiere ich doch direkt neuen Küchen
aus heute gibt's Bienenstich
[Musik]
Schnecken bienenstichschnecken könnt ihr
euch so vorstellen die tikuste das das
beste an dieser benenstichtorte die
kommt unten in der Backform darüber
kommen richtig fluffige softe ganz
flauschige Rollen mit einer
mandelbutterfüllung so habe ich es mir
ausgedacht wir werden mal schauen ob es
funktioniert hier auf der Messe ist auch
einiges los es kann auch sein dass hier
später einfach jemand in die Küche
platzt ich würde auch sagen ich setze
jetzt gleich den Hefeteig an und dann
zeige ich euch zwei drei Küchen also
hier sind die Zutaten für Hefeteig ich
habe einen Würfel Hefe 80 g Zucker etwa
20 Wasser 500 g Mehl dann nehmt ihr
Dinkel oder Weizenmehl ein Ei 220 g
Milch eine Teelöffel Salz und 80 g
weiche Butter gibt ihr die Hefe in der
Rührschüssel da kommt Zucker dazu und
Wasser und die Zutaten könnt ihr kurz
verrühren jetzt gibt ihr hier das Mehl
dazu die Milch das Ei und ganz zum
Schluss noch Salz und Butter und knetet
den Hefeteig für etwa 10 Minuten richtig
schön geschmeidig durch entweder mit den
Händen oder mit der Küchenmaschine geht
natürlich ein bisschen einfach we man
die händefreiit zum sauber machen so
schön auf Stufe 2 und währenddessen kann
ich schon mal
[Musik]
aufräumen jetzt ist der Teig perfekt
wenn er nicht mehr klebt ich nehme kurz
raus V zu einer Kugel und lass ihn dann
schön aufgehen so etwa für eine Stunde
bei Raumtemperatur oder falls ihr ein
Ofen habt mit Stufe dann auch gerne im
Dampfbackofen habe ich zu Hause mit
meinem
boschgerät jetzt hier kurz abdecken und
dann kann ich aber schon in der
Zwischenzeit eigentlich schon mal
Zutaten richten für die Bienen Kruste
aber ich würde sagen ich zeig euch
lieber in der Zwischenzeit ein paar
Küchen
ja
[Musik]
für die bienenstichmtelgruste nehme ich
200 g Mandeln das sind die gehobelten
100 g Zucker 100 g Sahne und etwas
Vanilleextrakt und für die Füllung habe
ich jetzt hier noch mal 100 g Butter 150
g gemahlene Mandeln 80 g Zucker ein Ei
und noch mal Vanilleextrakt jetzt machen
wir erstmal die bienenstichgruste dafür
nehmt ihr einfach die Mandeln den Zucker
die Sahne und Vanilleextrakt und gebt
alles in der Pfanne das muss nämlich nur
kurz aufgekocht
werden
[Musik]
einmal schön kochen bis der Zucker sich
löst so dann direkt runterschalten das
hier habe ich z.B auch gemacht das ist
Marmorkuchen kaiserschmn eine
Kombination die so noch nicht gab habe
ich mich einfach auf der Messe
ausgedacht und für euch gedreht
natürlich kommt nächstes Mal online
nächste
Woche so das kann ich jetzt hier direkt
vom her runter Zehen und die anderen
Zutaten auch mit miteinander verrühren
denn das ist ja die leckere
Buttermischung dann verrühre ich jetzt
hier die weiche Butter dann Zucker rein
Ei und
[Musik]
Vanilleextrakt ich nehme jetzt hier eine
Backform ich nehme die eckige i Backform
EMI ist immer perfekt zum Backen weil
sich alles wunderbar herauslöst und sich
die Backform auch wieder gut reinigen
lässt ich fette die jetzt einfach kurz
mit backtrenpray könnt auch einiss
Butter nehmen geht natürlich auch Butter
schmeckt natürlich noch besser aber ich
brauche jetzt nur ein bisschen was und
da kommt jetzt die Mischung rein
theoretisch hättet ihr auch einfach
falls ihr einen Ofen einen Herd habt
also ein Kochfeld mit flexinduktion
könnt ihr auch die Backform drauf
stellen denn im ist auch
induktionsgeeignet und dann hättet ihr
da sogar das ganze drin aufwärmen können
dann kommt jetzt mein lieblingsteig der
Hefeteig auch mein lieblingspart ich
ausroller aber ich brauch keine
Abstandsringe aber deswegen muss ich sie
nicht gleich
wegschmeißen dann auf der Arbeitsfläche
mit bisschen Mehl schön
[Musik]
ausrollen dann kommt jetzt hier die
leckere mandelbuttermischung
drauf
und jetzt einfach schön aufrollen es
geht auch ganz gut mit Hilfe der
Backmatte ich ma das jetzt so dass ich
jetzt hier etwa 15 Schnecken reinmache 1
2 3 und dann fünfe rein genau je nach
Form können ihr natürlich schauen wie
viele bei euch reinpassen denn je
weniger ihr schneidet umso dicker werden
sie je mehr ihr macht umso kleiner
werden Sie ganz einfach jetzt nehmen die
entweder ein stumpfes Messer zum
durchschneiden oder einfach bisschen
Zahnseite oder Küchengarn denn damit
habt ihr den Vorteil dass die Schnecken
nicht zerdrückt werden sondern direkt
von außen nach inen verquetscht werden
okay 15 das heißt ich Drittel das
erstmal und dann fünftle ich das
[Musik]
noch
oh die sehen so gut aus die kommen jetzt
direkt in den Backofen ich bin so
gespannt denn ich will sie ja später
umdrehen damit die bienentich gr oben
ist okay die sehen ziemlich gut aus bin
ich mal gespannt die sind ganz warm aus
dem Ofen ich habe jetzt leider meine
Serv PL atte vergessen aber ich probier
jetzt
abkühlgitter und dann schauen wir mal ob
das so
funktioniert oh wow es hat funktioniert
es hat funktioniert oh mein Gott ich sag
e ich glaube das Beste ist dazu einfach
entweder bisschen Vanillepudding mit
Sahne weil bienentich ist ja eigentlich
so eine Kombi manchmal aus
vanilleputding Buttercreme oder Sahne
oder einfach geschlagene Vanillesahne
wichtig ist auf jeden Fall dass ihr die
Hefeschnecken direkt nach dem Backen
rausstürzt damit die bienenstichkruste
schön auf den Hefeschnecken bleibt denn
ansonsten kannst schon in der Form
ankleben egal in welcher Form falls ihr
es doch mal kurz drin vergessen habt
einfach die Form kurz erwärmen von unten
und dann rausstürzen ich muss h übrigens
noch was reinstellen in meine Küche denn
ich habe heute ein Geschenk bekommen von
Marie Sophie für meine Küche und ich
habe versprochen das heute hier in meine
Küche reinzustellen Marie sophie hat mir
auch ganz ganz fleißig hier beim Backen
geholfen bei meinen
Cupcakes okay jetzt einfach eine
Schnecke abreisen
ne guckt mal von unten so von oben so oh
mein Gott es sind glaube ich die besten
Hefeschnecken aller Zeiten ich servere
gleich noch geschlagene Sahne dazu aber
ich probiere jetzt einfach schon mal
eine ist noch ganz heiß meine Hand
verbrennt aber es jetzt nicht
schlimm
wow
mhm
mh wisst i wie soll wir da entscheiden
wir hatten die barbiechnecken wir hatten
Zimtschnecken wir hatten schokoschnecken
wir hatten so viele Schnecken
Bratapfel die sind einfach alle gut aber
ich sag's euch die bienenstichschnecken
die sind noch mal die sind noch mal noch
ein Tick besser na ja ich würde mal
sagen schreibt mir gerne welche
Schnecken von meinem Blog bisher eure
Lieblinge waren probiert dieses Rezept
gerne aus Bienenstich Schnecken richtig
lecker serviert dazu ein bisschen
geschlagene Sahne oder genießt sie
einfach so denn sie sind auch so der Hit
aktiviert gerne die Glocke abonniert den
Kanal und lasst ein Kommentar da dann
gibt's auch weiterhin richtig viele
tolle Rezepte ganz liebe Grüße von mir
hier von der Nobilia Hausmesse ich hoffe
euch haben auch die Küchen gefallen
schaltet wieder das nächste Mal ein und
bald gibt's ganz viel küchencontent den
ich dieses jah noch richtig viele Küchen
und ich hoffe ihr habt da auch richtig
Lust drauf also bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
tschüss schau mich hinter der Kamera
alle an und fragen sich ob sie auch ein
Stück
bekommen doch grün grün grün sind alle
meine Kleider grün grün grün ist alles
was ich hab darum lieb ich alles was so
grün
ist vielleicht wird ja auch meine neue
Küch
[Musik]
grrün